good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller back from a week of absence as
you all know I broke my arm but enough
about me the SCP we're going to be
studying today is scp-323 object class
Euclid special containment procedures as
ap 323 is to be kept in a 17 by 17 by 3
meter concrete containment cell in site
91 the object is to be restrained in the
center of the cell with a 1 meter cubed
container of 8.8 centimeter thick
transparent armor
Lyde with one-way laminate which is to
be fit with one electronically locked
access port this container is to be
internally lit with the surrounding cell
kept dimmer to facilitate the one-way
laminate the cell is to be surveyed
remotely at all times and any signs of
activity are to be reported no personnel
are to enter scp-323 s containment cell
except to examine the integrity of
scp-323 s restraint measures the
restraint measures are to be examined by
weekly and any signs of damage are to be
repaired immediately all personnel who
enter scp-323 s containment cell are to
be accompanied by an armed guard
personnel are not to be with n scp-323 s
containment cell for longer than 45
minutes and any communication around
scp-323 is to be written or spoken in a
language other than French or English in
the event that scp-323 breaches
containment an instance of scp-323 - one
is formed personnel are to evacuate site
91 and the site is to be locked down
remote units are to be deployed to
destroy the body of scp-323 - one
following this armed personnel may be
sent in to re-establish the containment
of scp-323
[Music]
description scp-323 is the skull of an
unidentified servant measuring 55
centimeters long 27 centimeters wide and
31 centimeters tall with a pair of
antlers measuring 35 centimeters tall
and 46 centimeters from tip to tip
growing from the left and right sides of
scp-323 scp-323 shows signs of damage
consistent with outside exposure with
regular pitting scarring and weathering
across the object bleaching on the upper
surfaces and missing a lower mandible
the rear of the skull features an
approximately centered avoid gap
measuring 25 centimeters high and 23
centimeters wide giving access to an
interior space 16 centimeters deep this
gap shows signs of tool use indicating
that it was carved with tools possibly
stone scp-323 displays the ability to
react to aural tactile and visual
stimuli testing has revealed scp-323
appears to have a field of view similar
to that of other servants and has
responded to visual stimuli from up to
50 meters away the targeting of specific
members of personnel various attempts to
breach containment and the violent
reaction towards speakers of the French
and English languages suggest a level of
sapience however this is unconfirmed
scp-323 is capable of limited locomotion
typically in the form of small movements
and vibrations in most cases scp-323
will only locomote in the event of
various stimuli such as moving away when
touched or turning when personnel are
present within its containment chamber
scp-323 has demonstrated the ability to
make larger movement such as lunging at
personnel and repeatedly attempting to
force its way through containment
measures
scp-323 exerts an influential effect in
a radius extending roughly 15 meters
from itself individuals within this
radius will begin experiencing
cannibalistic thoughts and urges violent
outbursts and impaired judgment after
approximately one hour of continuous
exposure roughly 74 percent of
individuals who reach this point will
attempt to place their heads through the
gap present in the back of scp-323 with
efforts made to keep their mouths
uncovered if an individual is incapable
of fitting their heads through the gap
attempts will be made to bludgeon their
heads against nearby hard surfaces until
the point the individuals head fits the
individual loses consciousness or the
individual expires once the individual
has fit their head through scp-323 the
individual is classified as scp-323 -
one within ten minutes of putting a CP
3:23 on scp-323 - one will undergo
drastic physical alterations scp-323 -
one will experience rapid loss of body
fat body hair and pigmentation followed
by the rupturing of the distal phalanges
from the finger tips abnormal tooth
growth and the blackening of extremities
consistent with frostbite
additionally scp-323 - one appears to
experience greater strength and pain
tolerance than the average human
however scp-323 - one still appears to
be as susceptible to physical harm as it
was prior to its introduction - scp-323
scp-323 - one's metabolism will
experience a dramatic increase requiring
a constant caloric intake but starvation
occurring anywhere between fifteen to
thirty minutes if no self preservation
efforts are made in order to sustain its
increase metabolism scp-323 - one will
actively seek out and eat other
individuals for sustenance until
expiration in the event scp-323 - one is
incapable of
finding plentiful nourishment scp-323 -
one will make efforts to sustain itself
including limiting movement rationing
available food and auto cannibalism
scp-323 - one will only feed upon humans
it is presumed that scp-323 - one is
capable of receiving sustenance from
other sources but chooses not to
despite availability or ease of access
during the pursuit of individuals
scp-323 - one has been known to
occasionally make various statements in
the seven Ojibwe Potawatomi and Prix
languages as well as in the native
language of the instance it is not known
if these statements and the knowledge of
these languages is the result of scp-323
is anomalous influence or they originate
from scp-323 itself the following audio
log has been transcribed from
surveillance recovered during the 11th
of September 2006 containment breach of
scp-323 which resulted in the death of
12 personnel members before containment
could be re-established no accompanying
video surveillance could be recovered
playing now
[Music]
[Music]
awesome
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
scp-323 was recovered on the 9th of
december 1997 in the bittern lake
reserve part of the lala krong first
nation in Saskatchewan Canada
[Music]
small unregistered community had been
sustaining an activist CP 323 - one
instance by routinely murdering
individuals and leaving them out as
appeasement investigation revealed
individuals were involved who were
interviewed and subsequently
administered amnestics
and a cover story involving an
unidentified serial killer was
propagated a CP 323 - one at the time
suspected to be the anomaly died of
starvation during its transfer to site
91 the recorded number of deaths did not
appear consistent with the duration of
the scp-323 - one instance it is
suspected that scp-323 went through
several instances of scp-323 - one
before containment however no
irrefutable evidence supporting scp-323
- one's longevity has been uncovered
interview scp-323 - a james nami goose
an individual involved in the murders
and sustaining of scp-323 - one prior to
its containment was brought in for
questioning involving a CP 323 - one mr.
Nam ago remained unusually calm
throughout and after the interview
following the interview and containment
of scp-323 mr. Naumann goose was
administered amnestics and was
reintroduced to his community playing
log now time to record james namma goose
please state your involvement with the
murders there's a story of the cream man
final was calm we tried to control the
Windigo
give this people an advantage it was
just a story we didn't ask to the woods
[Applause]
the one deal and then we could leave
with him like we all do when we pass but
I was made to kill it would look at me
sometimes I'd hear in my mind feeling
watching me from nice this helped me
watch these people die final note no
mental effects similar to what mr. Nam
ago stated have yet to be reported by
staff who have interacted with scp-323
or scp-323 - one further investigation
into this is not planned however staff
are encouraged to report any atypical
thoughts or feelings experienced while
working with either
all right thank you very much for
listening and you're all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins Andrey Pichette dr.
mortis Cody tench Pierce M Hamlin sy7
actual rebellion fidelia's untie verbal
if you would like a personalized thank
you at the end of each of my videos on
some other cool stuff as well as at
patreon.com forward slash the volgen
thank you
you